(people shouting)
- In Kabul, the capital of Afghanistan,
life here is changing rapidly
under the new regime of the Taliban.
Now the Islamic Emirate of
Afghanistan is being proclaimed,
and it replaced the Afghan Republic
that was deposed in the middle of August.
Already the city's changing
visibly before our eyes.
The visual transformation's
quite striking.
(people shouting)
The city used to be covered with graffiti,
with paintings of Afghan national heroes,
of woman activists, of historical figures.
Now a fresh coat of paint
is going all over that,
and increasingly, the slogans
of the Islamic Emirate
are replacing the visuals
that used to characterize Kabul.
As you walk around, you
can see that merchants
are walking between cars,
selling big and small
flags of Islamic Emirate.
The white flag with the Islamic scripture
that has replaced the
black, red and green flag
of the now deposed
Republic of Afghanistan.
(people shouting)
There are protests now every
day, mostly led by women.
They are being dispersed by the Taliban,
and yet continue day after day.
The Taliban have proven themselves
to be a highly successful military force.
However, the fighters
don't have much experience
with the peaceful street
protests that we see now.
They haven't been trained,
they don't have riot equipment
and what they do is shoot in the air,
sometimes missing and hitting buildings.
(gunshots firing)
The fact that the new government
doesn't include any women
says a lot by itself.
And so that is the reason
why many are now protesting,
many of them are down
in the streets saying
if this government stays the way it is,
if there is no transformation,
then all of the achievements
of the last 20 years,
at least in the urban areas of Afghanistan
will be gone forever.
The Taliban haven't yet spelled out
what rules they will implement.
Many Afghan women are preoccupied,
preoccupied and alarmed by the fact
that they probably will not
be able to continue working
in many professions,
that educational
opportunities will be reduced.
The government has already
received international criticism.
It has not been recognized by the UN,
and yet for now, it seems
to be in firm control
of the city, despite these
occasional demonstrations.
(women shouting)